[Musique]
1665 à
1764 je fleurirai partout où l'on me
portera telle est la devise de la
Compagnie des Indes orientales à qui les
rois de France ont confié l'île Bourbon
suivant les autres puissances maritimes
européennes la France crée au 17e siècle
une compagnie de commerce pour coloniser
des territoir et en exploiter les
richesses c'est Étienne rau qui en 1665
à la tête d'une vingtaine d'homme prend
la direction de l'île les premiers
habitants survivent en cultivant des
légumes ou des céréales en élevant des
animaux en chassant ou en pêchant la
compagnie oblige les colons à
ravitailler en produits frais les
navires après 1715 elle leur impose des
cultures destinées à être vendu en
Europe ou à Maurice pour cela les
gouverneurs accélèrent l'introduction
d'esclav l'île passe donc de 12
habitants en 1663 à environ 22500 en
1764 dont 80 %
d'esclaves alors que le début du
peuplement est marqué par un métissage
entre les hommes d'origines diverse et
des femmes malgache indo-portugaises et
européennes les mariages entre Blancs et
Noirs sont interdits en
1674 mais dans la réalité cela est loin
d'être respecté d'ailleurs une langue
commune né le créol
1665 à
1764 le temps de la Compagnie des
[Musique]
Indes